was this fear campaign that if mle won
um he would be the sort of fascist you
know who would be a danger for democracy
just like um people in the US um talked
about Donald Trump in recent years or
people in Brazil talked about Shah bson
um mle was described as this H very
dangerous person who should be who
should not be president so this is the
reason why I think uh it was Masa
particularly who got uh more votes um
because mle was sort of um competing
with the rest of the opposition for the
anti-government vote uh he won that if
you if you take that as a primary as
another primary say then he won that
because he beat Patricia B who will not
be in the second ballot uh but the
government sort of Consolidated its
support um and got more votes I think
because of this fear campaign and
because it tried to focus it Tred to
avoid um economics basically because um
the presidential candidate is the
Minister of economy but our economy is
in shambles right now uh we have a 140%
annual inflation rate um an ongoing
recession uh poverty rates that are
through the roof um so it was smart of
the government to try to avoid U the
economic themes and just focus on how
dangerous we would be and I think that's
the reason why they got more votes but
it wasn't just the sphere campaign right
like Masa also engaged in a little bit
of uh I would say not exactly trickery
but almost like bribing people to vote
for him when it really got down to the
wire could I was even reading a little
bit about how you know people would show
up to bus stations and train stations
and see the government basically
communicating oh if Malay you know comes
into Power then here is how much your
ticket will actually be because it'll no
longer be subsidized by the government
and he'll slash all of these programs
which is a fairly compelling pitch to
people who are struggling financially
could you tell us a little bit about
like what was this very slimy campaign
that Masa was
running yeah I mean it was all very
sketchy uh and it wasn't just that um
for people who don't who haven't been to
Argentina uh bus tickets uh train
tickets Subway tickets are highly
subsidized uh particularly in Buenos
sidtis and so so a bus ride can cost
something like um seven cents of a
dollar uh when the true price should be
something like a dollar and so who's
paying for that of course taxpayers uh
it's only indirectly that they're paying
for that with for example this monstrous
inflation rate that we have U but it's
not something that you pay directly and
so what the government did was they they
actually installed um um like signs that
said you know if uh without a subsidy
you would be paying 10 times what you're
paying today um which was a very uh not
a direct but a very clear reference to
um the fiscal adjustment that both mle
and buid uh were proposing something
else that um Minister Masa did was he
actually uh cut taxes uh in these past
two months uh which is something that a
uh leftist um peronist government as we
call it here uh would never do um but
this time they they did do it um
Minister Masa sort of slashed uh income
tax uh for actually this was mostly for
people who are high earners uh in
Argentina but he basically slashed it um
and he also um implemented well he they
passed a law that Minister Masa sent to
Congress which would um and which is
effective now and sort of gives um money
back to taxpayers the V attacks it gives
it back basically to Consumers who use
their debit card in supermarkets uh and
Grocery Stores um so there there were
lots of measures put in place by the
government which are already fueling
inflation because uh the September rate
for example was uh
12.7% which was the highest uh monthly
rate in 30 years in Argentina um wow
really yeah I know right okay yeah um
and before that in August we we had you
know surpassed our record uh again so
this is like a continuous thing you know
every month we get higher inflation than
the previous one and it it is in part
because of these measures um they
weren't enough to sort of um call
markets down uh there still was a run
against the peso right before the
election
um for people to to to get a sense of of
what the exchange rate is here uh right
after um um the August primaries the
dollar was trading at something like 600
pesos um but right before the election
uh this past Sunday uh the dollar was
staining at something like a thousand
pesos so there was a there was
definitely a run against the peso uh
which minister Massa was unable to
contain um but still you know these
measures that he took these these very
populist measures uh they are very we're
used to them uh that that's probably why
I didn't even mention them in the first
place you know because we see that
happen uh repeatedly uh and regardless
of who the president is of what their
political affiliation is they all try to
take uh Implement measures that will G
get them uh the most votes right before
the election in the case of Masa was tax
cuts which alongside this fear campaign
I think were very
effective so you could say Malay is
already delivered his first tax cut just
through the fear of his election uh by
his political opponents but what you
know when when mle that's actually I'm
sorry that that's actually what he said
because he he has two seat in Congress
right now yeah he has two seats in
Congress uh one of them is actually him
uh he actually voted in favor of the tax
cuts and he told people you know this
was actually uh his doing all around
that he was forcing Masa to cut taxes
through his agendas let's return to the
election results for just a moment um as
you mentioned the uh front runner uh or
the top finisher here Masa got about 30
almost 37% of the vote mle
29.9% of the vote almost 30% um and then
uh Bull rck with almost 24% so actually
a fairly even split between the three
could you just explain to us the
difference between these three main
these three top finishing parties and
candidates Yeah so basically um in Sasa
you find uh the the representative of
the current Administration he is the the
minister of economy um he is sort of
like um the the shadow president if you
will because the our president has
largely uh gone out of stage he he's
doing nothing really nobody really cares
about what the president is doing since
like the beginning of this year when he
announced that he was not going to go
for re-election he's deeply unpopular uh
but Masa represents uh the peronist
party that of Juan Domingo Pon um who
back in the 40s and the 50s um
introduced populist policies uh which
it's hard to explain because the parist
party um has many faces um some of them
tend to be leftist some of them tend to
be rtist and Masa is a perfect example
of that Masa actually started his um
political career in a center right party
uh in a sort of libertarian party really
back in the late 80s uh and there are
some people who still remember him you
know as defending economic Liberty uh
like strongly very strongly but after
joining the parist party he sort of
defended whoever uh the parist in charge
was which made him uh actually oppose
you know uh Nester and Christina kishner
who were presidents uh from 2003 to
2015 um he was a minister for that
government he then resigned he ran uh as
a presidential candidate
against uh kirner's uh candidate um so
he's been going back and forth you know
between uh leftist and rtist positions
right now he's the representative of the
left in Argentina of the center left did
you want to go to some audience
questions
Zach yes there's quite a few that have
come in one is from naram shanuk says
Masa is not Center left he's a left-wing
populist I from what you were describing
it sounded to me like I I think these
terms get a little confusing across in
different context because populist well
you know giving out a bunch of goodies
ahead of the election that's a populist
move here in America we tend to think of
populism as anti-establishment figures
but it's a little muddled here because
he's part of the establishment but he's
also a populist but right and I I don't
know that mle you know he's often
described as a populist I don't know
that he is a populist but he's
anti-establishment there anything else
you want to add to the understanding of
these terms yeah people also describe
Malay as like a fascist or in keeping
with bolsonaro which is sort of not my
understanding of the policies that
Malaya is promoting I think people are
very imprecise with their
labels yeah um so in terms of labeling
um Masa is definitely the uh
establishment candidate I mean he's been
part of he's been in politics for
decades um he's actually calling for a
government of national Unity you know
he's actually courting these parties
these parties that um will not endorse M
he he's trying to get them um you know
to be part of a potential government by
him um I would call Masa populist
definitely uh because of the measures
that he took that he's taking um
and I think at this point he represents
basically all of the left in Argentina
the center left but also the far left uh
and the left just left you know um
because there I mean w with the far left
candidate out for the runoff um anyone
who feels leftist will vote for him but
again I think Masa can uh Masa has uh
switched you know skins in the past uh
he has been rtist he has been leftist um
and many people think he can actually
you know make another um 100 uh degree
turn so we don't really know what's
going to happen um and then you were
talking about mle as sort of a A
bolsonaro or trumpish figure um that's a
very interesting discussion um I
understand why many people have compared
mle to Trump or
bolsonaro I am not sure that that
comparison is uh completely accurate
because neither Trump nor bolsonaro were
libert I mean were self-described anarco
capitalist it's not that M it's not that
M right it's not that mle you know you
know calls himself just a classical
liberal or a Libertarian like he's he's
called himself an anarco capitalist hey
thanks for watching that clip of our
talk with Marcos Falcone about the
presidential candidacy of javar mle you
can watch the full conversation here or
another clip over here